[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mardi 28 novembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition
quelle ville de north pas pour demain
c'est la question posée par la
municipalité aux habitants et des
ateliers se tiennent en ce moment pour
réviser le plan local d'urbanisme commis
hier à la mairie de la commune
une réunion qui a permis de donner la
parole aux citoyens nous étions sur
place
comme chaque mardi le portrait de la
semaine sur une personnalité du
département inédit ce soit rencontre
avec fidji une chienne malinoise capable
de détecter les produits utilisés lors
d'un incendie criminel
elle fait partie de la brigade cynophile
de ben enfin c'est notre fil rouge dans
le 7-8 journal le dossier de la
rédaction sur le fait main dans les
yvelines épisodes de ce soir à
versailles consacrée à marie et
dominique à mono une maroquinière qui
s'est lancée dans la création
d'accessoires en cuir 600 hommes
mobilisés parmi eux les effectifs du
gign du raid de la gendarmerie et des
pompiers et des yvelines voici les
moyens utilisés hier au château de
versailles un exercice antiterroriste
s'est déroulée dans le plus grand des
secrets en plein coeur du parc du
monument opérations en perspective des
jo de 2024 et du renforcement de la
sécurité des grands sites touristiques
dans l'actualité du jour également les
patrons et porteurs de projets avaient
rendez vous au ski cuba guyancourt
elle est septième rencontre kreactive se
dérouler tout cet après midi c'est un
événement annuel organisé par créactive
c'est le réseau des femmes
entrepreneures de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines patrick
jacques de dixmude et nicolas
kirillovitch l'argent un sujet vaste qui
peut faire peur mais pourtant essentiel
à la réussite d'une entreprise est
thématique principale de la 7e édition
des rencontres
kreactive calculer son prix et défendre
ses marges
optimiser ses revenus et sa fiscalité
partenaires et chefs d'entreprise ont
évoqué l'argent sous tous ses angles le
temps d'une après midi avec un objectif
aider les porteurs de projets qu'il soit
féminin au masculin
donc ça me permet de vraiment complet
et bien maîtrisé le sujet pour être sûr
qu'à devant un client je suis vraiment
définir mais bon prix les marches qu'il
faut et ainsi de suite pour pouvoir
fonctionner sur aws et osons par exemple
nos valeurs voilà c'est une thématique
qui me parlait donc je voulais je
voulais y participer fort d'un réseau de
130 femmes chefs d'entreprise et
porteuses de projets huit tables rondes
étaient prévus pour ces rencontres
kreactive des rencontres ouvertes aussi
aux curieux en 2016 plus de 550 mille
entreprises ont été créées en france on
a quand même l'idée que
l'entrepreneuriat aujourd'hui c'est
possible pour tous les gens plus d'idées
ils ont envie de se lancer donc l'objet
aussi de ces rencontres c'est de leur
donner des clés pour essayer toutes les
personnes secret se lancer c'est tester
puis et ben l'association leur permet
d'échanger aussi beaucoup pour répondre
à la demande grandissante sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
créactive organise chaque mois plusieurs
événements le prochain est prévu lundi 4
décembre pour informer sur les risques
et les opportunités à l'international
c'est une tradition également du côté de
trappes les élus de la majorité
municipale ont débuté leur rencontre
publique de fin d'année plusieurs
réunions sont organisées dans différents
quartiers de la ville comme here soir
pour le village et cités nouvelles
notamment une occasion pour faire le
point sur les projets aboutis et ceux
prévus pour les mois à venir c'est aussi
le moment pour les habitants
d'interpeller directement leurs élus
écoutez à ce propos guy malandain maire
ps de trappes au micro de nicolas qui
rivalise je sens des choses qui vont les
choses qui vont pas le le questionnement
c c'est ce que j'appelle mon tout
simplement là la vraie la vraie
démocratie n'est pas artificielle et
naturelle vient qui veut pose la
question vous avez vu ce très diverses
dans tous les domaines des éléments de
réponse est toujours factuel et c'est
toujours vrai s'appelait s'appelait pam
essayer de répondre elle les grands
projets en investissement
c'est d'abord l'école l'école du shérif
rue pierre sémard le début le début de
travaux pour l'enfouissement de deux
nationalistes l'extension du parking
mahfouz ces rencontres à attrape vont se
poursuivre notamment jeudi pour le
quartier de la boissière plus de
précisions sur le site internet de la
ville de trappes autres réunions entre
élus et habitants c'est à maurepas je
vous le disais dans les titres et la
ville organisent des concertations et
des ateliers pour revisiter le plan
local d'urbanisme révisé ce plan local
ce document fixe les orientations d'une
commune en matière d'urbanisme
hier c'était un deuxième rendez vous qui
se tenait à l'hôtel de ville
il donnait à la parole aux morts passe
bien les arrêts g nicolas d'andrus cinq
objectifs pour un avenir proposer un
cadre de vie agréable ou encore
préserver la biodiversité
voilà les ambitions des ateliers
concertation entre moore passe bien les
citoyens étaient conviés lundi en mairie
à réfléchir sur le projet d'aménagement
et de développement durable intégré au
plan local d'urbanisme la parole des
habitants est importante si ce sont eux
qui vivent
je pense qu'ils peuvent rendre partie au
débat et
comment du coup qu'on intègre la fois la
croissance de la ville et une
biodiversité plus importante
donner la parole aux principaux
intéressés permet aux élus à terme de
proposer un plan local d'urbanisme
adaptés aux besoins des habitants
plus on est personnes à réfléchir sur un
projet plus on peut espérer que le
projet sera de qualité donc on est des
gens qui viennent de d'horizons diverses
et variées ça peut apporter des débuts
des vues de jeunes par exemple seront
pas obligatoirement exactement les vues
des deux retraités
donc l'idée c'est de justement mettre
des des verrous mettre des des barrières
pour empêcher justement une urbanisation
besonhez avec 44,5 pour cent des espaces
forestiers et naturel
maurepas possède un fort potentiel son
attractivité et son accessibilité ont
animé les ateliers ont fait une nouvelle
construction d'associer les habitants du
quartier font l'histoire de la fluidité
aussi dans la mobilité
le projet d'aménagement et de
développement durable sera débattu en
décembre lors du prochain conseil
municipal à la citoyenneté c'est une
problématique également à saisir dès le
plus jeune âge la ville de magny les
hameaux a pris le pas depuis plusieurs
années bonsoir thérèse mal m vous êtes
la 6e maire adjointe de la commune vous
êtes en charge de la communication et de
la démocratie locale alors magny les
hameaux organise depuis plusieurs années
une semaine de la sinne tout est de la
citoyenneté auprès des jeunes ça
s'adresse aux jeunes des dû délaisser pc
jusqu'à la troisième c'est un rendez
vous incontournable pour la pour la
commune pourquoi proposer cette semaine
de la citoyenneté exactement ça fait 6e
la sixième édition que magny les hameaux
propose cette semaine de la citoyenneté
donc elle s'adresse cette semaine aux
enfants de l'école élémentaire le
collège et les adultes sociolinguistique
d'accord là il y aussi des adultes une
population adulte qui est concerné
pourquoi c'est important parce qu'il est
important justement de préparer les
enfants à l'envi d'adultes donc la
citoyenneté hors groupe tellement de sa
vaste sujet justement donc nous vivons
dans un dans un pays
une république donc on leur apprend
l'institution comment comment
fonctionne justement les mairies enfin
voilà il ya plein de choses lors de
donner les moyens d'avoir les gestes de
premiers secours
pour nous c'est très important de les
ouvrir à ce qui va être une la vie plus
tard les remettre peut-être en tête
aussi des choses dans l'ordre puisque on
quand on est jeune on ne comprend pas
forcément comment fonctionne la mairie
obtenus restent les jours exactement
c'est ce que j'étais en train de vous
dire justement
donc ils ont une visite organisée auprès
de la mairie on va leur expliquer
comment fonctionne le conseil municipal
à la gendarmerie à quoi ça leur
gendarmerie
d'ailleurs ils ont eu ce matin le rallye
citoyen qui leur a permis d'avoir un
quiz et de d'avoir des questions en même
temps avoir les réponses est peut-être
apprendre pas mal de choses on proposera
d'ailleurs un sujet dans le statut de
journal sur ce rallye citoyen voilà les
deux coups aussi une découverte de la
déchetterie je crois alors voilà ils ont
alors ils ont eu déjà la visite a eu
lieu en octobre
oui parce que pour tout vous dire
vraiment cette semaine était prévu en
octobre mais a dû être décalé suite à
des événements bon voilà on va pas
rentrer dans le sujet une grève le ppms
donc du coup ils ont pu visiter la
déchetterie pour les sensibiliser au tri
des déchets et savoir justement que
quand on leur demande d'être lu or dieu
dans une poubelle ou à coups de pouvait
c'est il ya bien des raisons c'est pas
pour les embêter
déjà ce citoyen donc pour les pour les
plus jeunes ça permet aussi à ces jeunes
de pourquoi pas à prendre les choses à
leurs parents exactement du coup ça
sensibilise les parents parce que
combien de fois on a vu des jeunes dire
à la barre sommes là non il faut pas
faire comme ça nous on appris de cette
façon voilà donc comme toute façon comme
la vie évolue tout au cours des années
mais ça permet aussi aux parents d'avoir
encore les enfants qui sont là pour
l'heure pour les aider aussi à un livre
leur rôle de citoyen parce que la
citoyenneté ça peut être une notion même
flou pour des pour des parents pour des
adultes tout à fait c'est pour ça que
quand je le disais le rallye citoyen
quand on dit à partir de quel âge un
enfant peut être tenue responsable d'une
infraction
bon ben écoutez moi j'ai 55 ans chez un
peu découvert aussi cet âge là j'étais
surprise si je vous pose la question
monsieur carnet qu'est ce que vous
pouvez me dire à quel âge en fait tenu
responsable à partir de saison et ben
non
dix ans dix ans dix ans le tournoi tous
les jours exactement et c'est ça
l'intérêt c'est un apprendre tous les
jours et ses inserts justement la
commune est de justement ces jeunes à
à évoluer dans le bon sens alors une
question sur les temps forts il ya
plusieurs temps forts on a vu le rallye
citoyen il ya des quiz
oui les sensibilisations qui sont à voir
les cartes en main pour quoi faire le
carré de mémoire c'est le devoir de ne
devoir de mémoire est honorée les gens
qui sont battus pour la france donc ça
aussi il faut leur expliquer donc nous à
manier les mots nous avons pu justement
mettre en place ce fameux quart une
mémoire où tous les ans le laxisme la
fnaca travaille beaucoup avec les
enfants et donc travail c'est aussi
serein livre bon ça on a dû vous en
parlait déjà souvent santé les fils ou
en comment dire en lien il leur explique
ce que la guerre pourquoi ne pas la
faire et puis avec ce cet arbre qui est
symbolique de cette carte mémoire à
maniago hachiko biloba cze bat aussi ça
c'est le fait que c'est le salaire qui
est résister à la bombe d'hiroshima
c'est des choses qui sont importantes à
savoir et c'est pendant cette semaine
qu'ils apprennent aussi à toutes ces
choses à savoir aussi qu'on savait plus
tv fil 78 mais bien tv 78 7 depuis le
1er juillet plusieurs partenaires aussi
pour cette semaine
l'unicef qui vient aussi au contact des
enfants pour parler du droit des enfants
il y avait la 28e anniversaire de la
convention internationale
c'est tellement important le droit des
enfants dont on sert et que nous avons
tous des droits et des devoirs mais les
enfants bon bah on leur apprend à
l'aller eux ce qu'ils doivent pas fait
mais aussi on doit leur apporter des
choses pour devenir des adultes et
responsables et qu'ils ne soient pas
plus tard mallet en comment on dire en
rébellion contre la société alors
important aussi de dire que cette
semaine de la citoyenneté va se
poursuivre tout au long de l'année les
les les jeunes vont travailler avec
leurs enseignants leurs instits leur
instituteur pardon sur cette thématique
de la citoyenneté l'état fait et puis
bon bah donc il y aura aussi un grand
temps fort qui sera prévu pour le mois
d'avril 2010 8 d'accord je pense que la
date est arrêtée aujourd'hui ça serait
le 7 avril ouvert à toute la population
ou là nous avons beaucoup d'animations
sur l'esplanade de gérard philipe dans
le quartier de treichville à magny les
hameaux
donc ce sera l'occasion de le clôturer
de la plus belle des manières
cet événement d'art une remise de permis
et citoyen je crois aussi le permier
internet aussi ces permis internet qui
va être mis qui est voilà pendant cette
période là tous les ans a toujours un
succès ce qu'ils en font tellement
content d'avoir leurs petits permis
internet
donc ça s'est remis avec madame
christine mercier cayla l'adjointe aux
enfants dernière chose il nous reste
moins d'une minute les enfants sont
réceptifs à cézac sur la wii vous visez
aime beaucoup parce que bon ça là permet
déjà rien que d'apprendre les gestes de
premiers secours
personnellement j'ai pris mon car moi
j'avais la première fois j'ai pu
participer à cette chose là puisque nous
aller qu'on ne le faisait pas dans les
années soixante dix j'avais 23 ans
c'était mon employeur qui nous avait
payé quoi le
les cours de gestes de premiers secours
aujourd'hui vous avez vous êtes un
enfant de 10 ans vous pouvez savoir
comment mettre une personne en pls voilà
ou autre chose peut-être alerté enfin
c'est déjà des choses très important et
ça ils sont très réceptifs ce qu'ils
sont contents ils ont connaissent plus
parfois que leurs propres parents
merci à thérèse madame d'avoir étalé sur
six avoue 6e maire adjointe de la
commune de magny-les-hameaux en charge
de la communication et de la démocratie
locale et pour retrouver toute
l'actualité de la commune vous pouvez
vous rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran c'est tous
les mardis dans le 7-8 journal le
portrait de la rédaction consacré à ceux
qui font les yvelines elle a 7 ans et
travaille pour la brigade cynophile de
la gendarmerie de ben fidji est une
chienne malinoise unique en ile de
france c'est la seule à pouvoir détecter
des produits utilisés lors d'un incendie
criminel
une rencontre signée cani lambert
toujours plein d'entrain pour aller
travailler fidji prend son rôle très à
coeur
aujourd'hui sur le camp militaire de
bonnes séances d'entraînement après
qu'un collègue est posée différents
produits s'est elle de jouer
allez on y va pas bouger tu attends une
minute alors tu cherches il ne faut pas
plus de quelques minutes à la malinoise
pour marquer l'emplacement voilà si
fidji est aussi enthousiaste c'est parce
que pour elle il s'agit d'un jeu et
pourtant son travail est très sérieux
elle détecte les produits utilisés lors
d'un incendie criminel
alcool à brûler white spirit ou essence
rien n'échappe à son flair quel que soit
leur état
il ya un produit qui a été brûlé un
produit qui a terrassé à l'eau est un
produit qui est resté nature pourquoi
ces trois états parce que
quand sonne aux mille feux les produits
ont été brûlées donc ce qui altère et ce
qu'ils changent leurs odeurs et ses
propositions quand les pompiers sont
arrivés ça a été lavé donc pour
apprendre le chien a travaillé sur du
produit brûlé sur du produit la lave et
suite à une intervention des pompiers et
sur la matière à natal natural poissy et
trouver le produit qui n'a pas encore
été brûlés
comme elle ils sont une dizaine dans le
pays une spécialité unique en ile de
france qui votent à fidji des opérations
régulières
cette année elle a participé à 19
interventions avec son maître une équipe
complices car la chaîne de 7 ans a
parfois ses humeurs yves est l'un des
rares à pouvoir l'amadouer et surtout la
comprendre ou sweden où il vient d'être
papa car oui et c'est mon chien oui je
travaille avec elle c'est pas communauté
de travail parce que si on utilise notre
chien que comme un outil de travail bas
m'ont donné ça va pas marque ça va pas
aller donc c'est vraiment le binôme jeu
je travaille avec elle j interprète en
langage humain ce que le chien ne
donnons langage en langage chien je
dirais elle me donne des indices en
charge de les traduire en langage humain
pour que mes collègues puisse
interpréter et puisse avancer sur leur
sur leur zone
un véritable duo formé pendant 14
semaines à gramat au centre national
d'instruction cynophile de la
gendarmerie iv fidji ont été accordées
selon leur caractère ne pas mettre un
chien qui va être hyper speed 1 m qui va
être calme et l' inverse
donc on essaie d'équilibrer sur les
caractères on est la seule
administration à le faire ça marche pas
mal du tout du début de mission jusqu'à
la fin de mission il faut qu'elle
travaille avec la même motivation est le
même le même entrain un chien qui au
bout d'une minute de travail va tout
laisser tomber parce qu'il en a marre
nous ne nous intéressera pas donc le jeu
ça peut s'apprendre un chien la
persévérance au jeu c'est inné soyez là
soit il la pâte
une mission qui se termine toujours par
une récompense un moment de jeu avec son
maître fidji devrait servir encore
jusqu'à ses 12 ans elle aura ensuite
droit à une retraite bien méritée la
gendarmerie recherche toujours des
chiens pour renforcer son équipe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un rendez vous mensuel à présent le
dossier de la rédaction série de
reportages cette semaine sur le fait
main dans les yvelines ce soir focus sur
la maroquinière marie-dominique à monod
à versailles elle s'est lancée en 2015
dans la création d'accessoires en cuir
un sujet de camille lambert du
portefeuille au sac à main ici chaque
pièce est unique
des créations que les visiteurs ont pu
découvrir à la cour des métiers d'art de
versailles une première pour marie
dominique hamonou je présente de la
petite maroquinerie
essentiellement à destination des hommes
parce que j'aime bien de travailler des
collections un peu coloré je trouve que
ça change de ce contrôle se trouvait
actuellement dans le commerce qui est
toujours un peu noir marron etc
j'ai commencé à beaucoup travailler en
ligne mais là ce que j'aimerais c'est
c'est pas me faire connaître sur
versailles déjà puisque j'habite à
versailles et et puis sur les yvelines
en général un échange avec le public
pour transmettre et partager son savoir
faire
ce fait des démonstrations que tu
reprennes scellier donc avec une pince à
coudre et c'est une culture qui se
réalise à la main avec un fils et deux
aiguilles c'est une culture qui est qui
est garanti quasiment à vie très solide
et qui rend qui fait un point magnifique
qu'on ne peut réaliser qu'à larmes une
méthode acquise auprès d'un artisan
maroquinier d'hermès et avec un c ap /
famille c'est chez elle que la jeune
femme met en pratique ses compétences
depuis deux ans il découpage collage
elle réalise environ une quinzaine de
pièces par semaine entièrement à la main
aujourd'hui porte cartes en cuir doux
coller une première couche de teinture
donc ouais c'est pour finir la tranche
en fait jusque là on voit on voit bien
qu'il ya les deux les deux cuir collé et
donc la tranche elle va finir une
teinture qui qui recouvre les deux c'est
toujours un peu travailler avec mes
mains
faut dire que mon père était très
bricoleur et il était mécanicien donc en
fait on a toujours un petit peu bricolé
dans la famille donc j'ai toujours un
peu travailler avec mes mains et quand
il ya trois ans je me suis posé la
question d'une reconversion
professionnelle c'est vrai que je me
suis dirigé dans ces voilà quoi un
travail qui s'inscrit également dans une
démarche écologique
la créatrice récupère ses cuirs en
ressourcerie c'est du réemploi donc cédé
cuir qui proviennent de chutes et de
une série de grandes maisons donc c'est
pas ramené cuir de qualité mais qui sont
réemployés qui ne finissent pas à la
benne parce que c'est leur destination
au final donc ça me permets moi de
travailler des cuirs de qualité et de
proposer effectivement des produits qui
sont abordables pour tous vendre 30
euros pour les plus petites pièces les
sacs peuvent aller jusqu'à 189 euros à
l'avenir marie-dominique soit encore
plus développé le sur mesure un terrain
de jeu et de création infini pour
refermer ce journal du football c'est le
nouvel homme fort de l'étoile sportive
de trappes
abderrezak guessoum est le nouveau
président du club cette année depuis
cette année un club qui compte plus de
mille deux cents licenciés il a succédé
à mustapha larbaoui en poste depuis 14
ans avec quel objectif pour le s trappe
et quels axes pour développer la
formation
entretien avec michael et demi d'euros
patrick jacques de dixmude pour les
moyens techniques
nous sommes sur le terrain synthétique
du stade gilbert chant 5 à mes côtés
abderrezak guessoum le nouveau président
de l'étoile sportive de trappes il
remplace le l'emblématique on peut le
dire mustapha allaoui qui était en place
au club de 2003 à 2010 est deux
septennats
voilà abderrezak comment ça se passe
depuis la rentrée vous êtes en place
depuis cet été
comment ça se passe tout simplement bah
ça va ça va ça va très bien nous avons
repris toutes les actions que vous savez
la wii avait mis en place au sein du
club donc
à l'heure actuelle aujourd'hui je peux
vous dire qu'on est on sera à peu près
1200 au club distancié ça encore un
record parce que la saison dernière on
était 1009 licenciés donc on a fait à
peu près une augmentation de 200
licenciés donc voilà c'est le fruit du
travail de safa larbaoui de toute
l'équipe d'éducateurs qui était en place
moi j étais aussi en place en tant que
référent sécurité au club et en tant que
éducateur à l'école de foot donc voilà
c'est un travail de tout le monde de
tout le monde
les résultats sont là aujourd'hui en
terme de licenciés en termes d'éducateur
en termes de dirigeants ça se passe bien
ça démarre on est en plein boom voilà et
j'espère que ça va encore continuer et
puis on va recevoir tous des actions qui
sont déjà menés 2 au sein du club à
savoir bombe à toutes les équipes qui
sont en ligue
l'académie qu'on a maintenu encore pour
cette année donc une reprise depuis le
23 octobre
donc voilà pour cette saison c'est
reparti sur toutes les actions déjà mis
en place par mustapha larfaoui et
comment fait justement pour succéder à
mustapha la ba oui il était là depuis
deux septennats comment fait pour lui
succéder est ce que ce n'est pas trop
dur
non on va pas dire que c'est trop dur
c'est simplement effectivement s'est
passé derrière un bonhomme comme lui
voilà moi je le conçois sais j'ai côtoyé
pendant trois quatre ans j'étais à côté
de lui pour succéder à mustapha ben oui
il suffit de rester dans la pérennité
dans la pérennité des actions qui ont
été déjà mis en place au sein du club et
du contenu et de les accompagner de les
améliorer
et puis voir créer d'autres actions s'il
est possible
voilà c'est ça la comptine moi je dis on
est sur la continuité
de ce qui a été fait au sein du club
pour ma première année ça va être de
s'asseoir en tant que président de de
regarder comment ça s'est passé de
garder ce qui ce qui est bon ce qui est
bon d'améliorer voire créer si possible
voilà donc c'est pas difficile c'est pas
difficile il suffit simplement de suivre
la feuille de route qui a été donné l'un
de vos principaux objectifs ça sera
sûrement l'équipe première équipe
première qui jouent actuellement r4 est
ce que l'objectif c'est de d'évoluer la
saison prochaine en r3 je vais pas je
vais pas le cacher a effectivement
aujourd'hui
chez les jeunes c'est parti en u15 et
u17 u19 nos équipes une sont tous en
ligue et il évolue au à tous
pratiquement vu le début de saison qu'a
démarré
des bons résultats en u19 en 15 ans u17
donc c'est bien parti voilà mais bon
s'il ya une montée pourquoi pas c'est
sympa c'est ça va être bien pour le
travail des éducateurs pour l' aventure
humaine pour les jeunes mais
effectivement aujourd'hui l'équipe
senior oui c'est la seule équipe qui
évolue en r4 aujourd'hui et notre
souhait serait qu'elle soit la saison
prochaine en r3 il ya possibilité
on les a vus jouer on les a vus ils sont
en place là on a un début de saison un
peu difficile mais il faut pas
s'inquiéter et encore du temps le
championnat juste de démarrer
voilà ils vont se ressaisir et
l'objectif bien sûr l'équipe seniors
c'est l'équipe fanion celle qui va tirer
tout le monde de toutes les équipes d'en
bas qui valait tirer et si on veut
garder nos jeunes pour l'avenir du club
il faut que cette équipe fanion soit
vraiment elle évolue au plus haut niveau
de lalique et comment expliquez vous
cette différence de niveau entre les
jeunes et sept équipes seniors ont sur
l'équipe senior jeu on est sur une
une équipe on va dire me jeunes vimy
anciens on est encore actuellement
encore cette année c'est une équipe qui
évolue depuis six ans à être quatre on a
frôlé il ya deux saisons les démonter on
n'était pas très loin
on n'était pas très loin des montées
malheureusement on n'a pas pu
donc voilà il ya un renouvellement cette
année on a injecté entre cinq et six
jeunes u19 qui sont sur l'équipe des
seniors avec arnaud voilà on y croit
derrière les u19 qui pousse encore on a
une sacrée équipe cette année donc c'est
des gens qu'on va récupérer encore
l'année prochaine
donc c'est pour ça qu'il est important
cette année pour moi je le dis important
qu'on qu'on passe le cap là avec les
seniors dès cette saison de la r4 on
passe à l'eire 3 pour qu'on puisse tirer
tout le monde qu'on puisse garder ces
jeunes là et qu'on puisse avoir l'année
prochaine une équipe une équipe encore
un peu plus jeunes qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter abderrezek guessoum pour
cette première année c'est ma dernière
question
ce qu'on peut me souhaiter c'est que
cette année se passe bien
voilà qu'on puisse prendre les rênes du
club tranquillement sereinement qu'on
puisse continuer à travailler ce qu'on a
mis en place voilà ce que je souhaite
c'est ça on est là pour nos enfants on
est là pour les enfants de la ville
ils sont derrière justement voilà ils
sont derrière
voilà et je souhaite que ça change pas
après ça change pas le club est déjà en
place et rien dit à tous et tout ce
qu'il faut
il suffit de suivre il suffit de
continuer le travail
et puis voilà puis les résultats seront
là merci beaucoup
abderrezak on vous souhaite le meilleur
pour cette année à trappes
merci je vous remercie fin de ce set 8
journal c'est disponible en replay sur
notre site internet et notre application
tv 78 excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]